all right it is now time for paul's
picks thanks to taylormade productions
for sponsoring this segment summer is in
full swing and entertaining expert paul
zone is back with us with his must-haves
to keep you glowing and going this
season welcome back thanks for having me
there's a lot going on this time of year
right a lot going on okay whether it's
for your skin or whether you're going
shopping or events
yes yes let's start with skincare let's
start with skincare with this wonderful
duo from olay with their niacinamide
plus peptide 24. okay so what this is
going to do it's going to help with the
wrinkles it's going to help hydrate
because it's so hot and so dry here in
las vegas so it's going to help with
that it's going to help to correct
uneven tones and it's healthier looking
skin with 99 pure niacinamide and you
might say paul why is this in the
package because it's a two pack and if
you pop into sam's club
yes if you pop into sam's club you get
eight dollars off between now and august
7th so that's that's right and that's
just one time application at night put
it on put it on the morning at night get
that hydration going we need it all
right what's next speaking of hydration
next up we have some back to school
meals made easy with smart finals so i
love smart and final it is one trip and
that's it they have everything you need
including this line called sun harvest
which is organic and it's much more cost
effective and they also have a green
line of things like compostable forks
and spoons in detergent and everything
like that so it's better for your wallet
and it's better for mother nature
breakfast is made easy right here with
some granola and some peanut butter nut
clusters we've got some peanut butter so
you know one click and that's it if you
go to smartandfinal.com and they have an
app so download the app and you'll love
it smart final makes it easy yes they
make it so easy so easy and what about
this summer drink oh yeah next up we
have absolute so absolute has teamed up
with garcelle bouvier to create this fun
front yard citrus situation here so you
know absolute vodka is a perfect
cocktail for any summer soiree so
they've created this cooler together
inspired by the different flavors so
this is the lime they have grapefruit
they have citron they have a wide
variety of different flavors of coolers
and so not only is it a table but it's
also a cooler so you fill this with ice
and everybody go to the front yard get
together have an absolute cocktail and
really celebrate that's a great backyard
the balcony where can you get that you
can get this at reserve bar dot com
order it and it's a great gift too for a
summer sorority
i definitely i agree i agree okay next
up summer shopping summer shopping back
to school back to school the kids are
going back to school well jcpenney has
you covered it's your one stop shop for
all things back to school for the kids
they have a wide variety of items from
classics like this fun denim jacket
right here they have denim pants they
have these cute shoes and they're such
great prices you can go to jcpenney or
jcp.com and they have all they have
husky they have adaptive clothes so it's
really for every kid in every ability
and they have coupons i love a good
coupon at jcpenney.com because hello
everybody's on the budget this time of
year right exactly and back to school
for the kids but also for the parents
too
all right and last but certainly not
least um coffee cocktails love a coffee
cocktail so we have some liquor 43 so
this is the most popular spanish liqueur
in the world it's 43 natural ingredients
and i get a lot of vanilla from it so it
makes a wonderful cocktail called the
carrijo so it's a shot of espresso a
shot of the liqueur 43 and it's
absolutely delicious and we also have a
horchata with liquor 43 that is actually
vegan so it's delicious you can do a fun
little pina colada with that you can
pick these up at total wine or drizzly
has been my best friend the past couple
years you go on drizzly app and they
will deliver it to you you can have
wonderful cocktails you have the best
tips that's why you're the entertaining
expert okay thank you so much paul for
being here these are great all right we
will send it to break and we'll come
right back